le jeudi soir dans le quartier kennedy
de blois c'est la soirée des black
panthers les ados de 13 14 ans viennent
s'entraîner d'arrache-pied une fois par
semaine par éviter toutes les corps et
donc d'avoir on sait chauffer tout pour
madame mitrow on est hainard n'était
d'un centre et on savait pas quoi faire
on était là pour discuter et tout et on
met tout haut de la musique et c'est là
qu'ont commencé à danser à tarnos pas et
tout est grâce à nos animateurs bas nous
ont ils nous ont dit bah pourquoi pas
pendant les vacances
bah on y va faire des cours de danse et
un an plus tard voilà le résultat
si vous le d'énergie qui créent leur
corps et et les répètes seule aire la
haye la coach chorégraphe du groupe
à
ap
genre transmet pas parce qu'ils savent
déjà dansé de la fraude en 6 que quand
vous mangez plus d'imagination c'est
plus moi qui écris déclaré avant de
regarder les vidéos je m'inspire et
comme j'aime danser depuis longtemps je
parle pour moi c'est énorme a dû faire
décorer
[Musique]
en fait me fait plaisir parce qu'en fait
ça me libère en dehors des courges pu
sortir je vais faire de la danse
profiter de mes amis rigoler on peut
faire plein de choses devraient aller
faire des doubles à ce sens à tous vos
rêves zurbains les années jouer la
maison de bégon très prochainement
l'objectif du service jeunesse de la
ville était de les faire sortir du
quartier et qu'elle devienne autonome
[Musique]
la première phase et mais chez moi
personnellement c'est ma motivation pour
aller au travail si elle n'était pas la
personne je je qu'est ce que je ferais
ce mille pétillant d'énergie elles sont
gentilles poli bien éduqué c'est tout ce
qu'on veut et franchement c'est juste
magnifique quoique ce travail avec ces
jeunes là à la base on dansait pour le
plaisir
il venait s'entraînant les regarde et on
se moque un peu d'élan et charrier et au
fur et à mesure on a vraiment cru en eux
on les a vus dans ses baskets
ils sont partis faire aussi des danses
dans d'autres vies et pour le coup voilà
ils savent que notre soutien et tous les
grands frères de de leur quartier
voilà le soutien des grands frères est
important pour ces jeunes filles dans le
quartier elles se sentent respectés et
admirés
de quoi leur donner une grande confiance
pour les années à venir quoi qu'elle
fasse dans la vie
à l'aller